effectivement ça s'appelle pas un
sécateur mais un économe pour la plupart
ces adolescents se mettent en cuisine
pour la première fois leur mission
réaliser des salades de fruits et des
smoothies pour ce faire ils peuvent
compter sur les conseils des plus
anciens comme yannis sous la direction
de brigitte si on écoute la fraise et
qu'après on la met dans l'eau et malo
elle va rentrer dedans et ça sera placé
rarement de la cuisine enfin je fais pas
du tout moi j'ai coupé banane et comme
on lui a appris à couper en lamelles il
savait pas ce que c'était les lamelles
de couper en lamelles la banane pour
mettre dans le souci trouve que c'est
très bien c'est ce que je fais avec mes
petits enfants aussi je leur prépare des
gâteaux et voilà des dizaines d'années
les séparent mais ces ateliers sont là
pour les réunir
mise en place en octobre 2016 la ville a
souhaité favoriser le lien inter
générationnel
c'est une lutte qui est sur le
territoire parmi les deux villes celle
qui a le plus de seniors de plus de 60
ans une somme un taux de 24 6% et la
recette fait déjà des adeptes
je trouve bien de faire des cuisines de
l'audi
il faut découper comme ça après j'ai
j'ai fait comme nous ont fait moi j'aime
beaucoup les jeunes et plus bon et puis
le rap rendent un peu puisque moi je
sais qu'à l'époque ma mère a montré
comment il fallait faire sauf
s'ingéniant à refaire ne reste plus qu'à
déguster le fruit de leur labeur
prochaine étape faire pousser les
ingrédients avec les beaux jours des
ateliers potager seront organisées une à
deux fois par mois